now to the wild weather in California
where parts of the state remain under
winter storm warnings in the meantime
residents in the southern part of the
state are pleading and pleading is the
word for help here with many still
stranded after last week's
record-breaking snowfall they are
struggling Jonathan bigliotti reports
from hard hit Crestline California
surrounded by snow the situation in
Crestline is dire with the roof of the
only grocery store collapsed residents
in this town of ten thousand have lined
up to receive free food
73 year old Carol Wolfe waited for three
hours with her neighbors in mind the
neighbors across the street they have
two little kids they
if you have a neighbor I've got a whole
bag here I have a neighbor so this is
your second time back because you
couldn't get stuff yesterday right with
snow encasing cars and few roads to
drive on we joined wolf on her nearly
mile long snowy hike back to her
impassable neighborhood
it's been nearly two weeks now yes and
this is the state of your road yes
meanwhile in Utah powerful Avalanches
led to hours-long road closures in big
Cottonwood Canyon outside Salt Lake City
search and rescue teams were deployed
but thankfully no reports of injuries
back in San Bernardino County
firefighters have been shoveling snow
off roofs in an effort to prevent more
collapses
we brought you some milk and some
groceries when we reached Carol Wolfe's
home we met her neighbor Rick Sawyer a
grateful father
I got a two-year-old and a
three-year-old and it's
been rough a special delivery from
neighbor to neighbor and I have some
I'll bring it over a little later I
appreciate it Carol thank you
that was Jonathan bigliotti reporting
Jonathan thank you